so
what uh was the actual process of
fasting
she said 16 8 time restricted so
intermittent fasting but you also
mentioned the three out
of the three day water fast what did
that feel like
and you also said training during the
three day yeah
how did that feel oh can you give me
some details of absolutely this is
fascinating
so i do three days water fast
uh four times a year nice for me
i do it everybody is different but for
me i do it after
uh new year's because during the the
early days that's when i
i eat bad foods and i drink i see it
more like a like a cleansing you know
like a
like like a detox sort of speak mental
too like psychologically yes
i do it after the new years right before
the summer
cut for the beach yeah yeah after the
summer because of the summer i've been
partying a little bit sometime let
myself go and right before the
the holidays and um i've tried the doc
dr fungi says to me said george
everybody is different
because i'm a very active person and
everybody has a different genetics so
so for me i i feel that
three days is the sweet spot because i
still train
during those three days the first day
the first two days i don't change
nothing
i train regularly on a rig on my regular
schedule however on the on the third day
i modify a little bit i i do something
more
[Music]
more easy and that's how i do it
and i've tried before because i when i
say
three days as my sweet spot i've tried
to go
up to five days but the problems is
after my third days i
i found out that i had a big problem
sleeping i got into a
hyperactive mode yeah they call that the
untogether uh
uh mode you know like you you you you
your brain
i mean it's amazing your creativity is
at its peak
but you cannot sleep very well and
sleeping
for me i think it's very important so
that's why i do three days for me it's
my sweet spot
that's interesting you're right it's the
four or five days when you start
see sleep is not important for me so the
creativity is really important
so it's very interesting with the places
your mind goes after a few days
you're right but uh i mean
what does it do to your mind so you
mentioned your body likes it
in terms of training does it um do you
find that it helps you focus and think i
mean you're one of the
great strategic thinkers in terms of
martial arts does it help
with learning does it help with thinking
does it help with strategizing and all
that
well unfortunately i got into fasting
after i retired i wish i would have i
really wish people
asked me would you have done it during
the time that you competed and the
answer is yes
i think we live in a society that were
bombarded by
publicity oh buy this eat protein
this that and fasting nobody makes money
with it because there's nothing to sell
you know
i think that's why a lot of people have
not
heard about it and even my for myself if
someone would have talked to me about
fast the benefits
of fasting when i was training
before i got sick i would probably have
ignored ignored him because it
i'm not you know it was it's hard to
believe
sorry it sounds ridiculous yes it's
gonna help your mind and you're going to
gain muscle potentially
exactly and and perhaps people have
talked to me about it but i
kind of it went in one of my hair and
got out
from the other side you know but uh it
really changed my
my life and i i'm dying i was diagnosed
with ulcer colitis
and it helps me get rid of all my
symptoms what i do is
i know a lot of people have those
circulations and and
for me i cannot recommend it to to other
people because everybody is
it's different but for me i made a lot
of research
of how people from the circulators got
better and i found out that a lot of
people that got that condition get
better in the natural witcher fasting
eating fermented food
collagen and like bone broth and
stuff all i got and it made a huge
difference in my life i just wish i
would have known that before
you